تهتز الألسنة في حديقة حيوان هيوستن، وتتجه
كل الأنظار نحو أكبر سكان حديقة الحيوان، وهو
سلحفاة تبلغ من العمر 90 عامًا تُدعى السيد
بيكلز، وقد تمكن من إنجاب ثلاثة
مخللات صغيرة تم تسميتها بما يتماشى مع
موضوع المخللات، لذلك أُطلق على والدهم ديل غيركين
وهالابينو البالغ من العمر 90 عامًا لقب  تم الاحتفال
بمباراة فاصلة بسبب رجولته
مع أتاباوي، هل من المهم
أن يتمكن من إنجاب هؤلاء الأطفال في سن
90. إنها مشكلة كبيرة، لذا من المهم أن
يتمكن من إنجابهم، ولكن أيضًا ما
حدث لطاقم رعاية الحيوان لدينا، حارس علم النسك لدينا  كن في
المكان المناسب في الوقت المناسب،
عثر الحارس على السيدة بيكلز وهي تضع بيضها
ونقلها إلى مكان الأمان. تربة هيوستن
لا تساعد على احتضان بيض
السلحفاة المشعة المهددة بالانقراض موطنها
مدغشقر. الآن أصبح السيد بيكلز
لاري كينغ
عالم السلحفاة على الرغم من أن الحقيقة هي أن مقدم
البرنامج الحواري الراحل أنجب طفله الأخير وهو
في السادسة والستين من عمره، لذا فإن لاري راكب رمح مقارنة بالسيد
بيكلز الذي أظهر ابن لاري
خوفًا صحيًا من الضفادع السامة لذلك
أكله الكلب، لا، لن يؤذيك
مثل  لاري السيد بيكلز لديه رفيق أصغر سنًا بكثير،
السيدة بيكلز تبلغ من العمر 53 عامًا. لم يكن لدى الزوجين
سوى سلحفاة واحدة أخرى،
لذا فإن الحصول على ثلاثة في وقت متأخر من الحياة
يشبه إلى حد ما السلحفاة في
أكياس الشعر التي تزحف ببطء شديد
ولكن عندما تكمم شعر لولي
السلحفاة  انتصارات
بطيئة وثابتة فاز السيد بيكلز بالسباق
لإنجاب genimos
CNN نيويورك الأجنبية